now a troubling story of left-wing
intolerance out of South Florida tonight
because Fox News political political
analyst giano Caldwell says he was asked
to leave a Miami Cafe over his political
views and the discussions he was having
with friends while he was at the
restaurant now Caldwell tweeted over the
weekend quote I can't believe what just
happened I met up with friends for
breakfast I had Paradise books and bread
in North Miami and while we were there
having discussions about politics we
were told by the owner that we were not
welcome there because we aren't
politically aligned uh out which is
outrageous you know now Paradise books
and bread they said in a statement in
response quote a group of people came in
ordered their food sat in the inside
corner talked quite loudly for over an
hour a lot of what they were discussing
was very troubling specifically when
talking about women in degrading ways as
well as using eugenic arguments about
their thoughts on Roe v Wade once was
clear that they were finished with their
meal we told them that our views don't
align and that the language that they
were using was unwelcome in our space
they were offended the vapors anyway
none of that sounds very tolerant or
inclusive or even believable to me but
that's what they're saying here to
explain more the author of this is a
great book taken for granted our friend
Fox News political analyst General
Caldwell
I want to just remind people you lost
your little brother and you're moving
you move with your other brother down to
Florida to keep your family safe you're
moving other family members down there
to keep them safe
you now have a new calling to help save
lives in cities like Chicago where your
innocent brother was was murdered back
in June you're working with Congress
you're working with John Walsh you do an
incredible work it's become a calling
for you you're there were you ever
talking about anything involving
Eugenics anything degrading towards
women because I know you to be a pretty
good Christian that doesn't sound like
you to me
absolutely not I was not saying anything
like that and thank you Sean for having
me and being an advisor to me on my
brother since he was murdered back in
June but I'll tell you Sean for some on
the left intolerant has become certainly
uh the exception uh and certainly uh the
norm not the exception and I'm gonna
tell you from what I experienced in that
conversation I met up with some folks
that live in my building uh here in
Miami my first time ever hanging out
with them first time hanging out at this
this particular establishment what we
talked about was Fox how do you like
working at Fox was their question to me
are you a conservative in fact I am I
have a book out call taken for granted
how conservatism can win back the
America's liberalism fail get it get a
copy I talked about my brother I talked
about the work that I'm doing with
Congress on Capitol Hill for victims of
violent crime then a owner comes over to
the table and she says I've been
listening to your conversation and you
are not welcome here and I said did I
say anything to you that triggered you
she said said no we're just not
politically aligned how dare her this is
modern day Jim Crow to me I can't
believe that me being a black man in
America to give my views on conservatism
which I believe saved my life my
Christian values saved my life in the
life of many other people that I know be
told that I cannot be in an
establishment this makes no sense to me
if you're not capitulating to their
narrative their views you are unwelcome
and that should not happen whether it be
in Florida or anywhere in the United
States of America we should be far
beyond this but that's what I
experienced on Saturday in this
restaurant it's outrageous anything you
plan to do are you going to sue them
well I'm I'm thinking about what I'm
doing next very carefully people can
follow me on social media at giano
Caldwell for my next steps but I got to
tell you they've been taking a hammering
over on social media people don't like
that because this can happen to anyone
that happens
who's a black conservative that's a
great Point too and we see this over and
over again when is anybody that works at
a restaurant and I worked at them for
you know 10 years of my life uh give a
rip about what somebody's talking about
at their table some of your business
it shouldn't be any of this lady's
business she to me she seemed like a
from her how she was moving like a white
Progressive and what I found out is a
lot of the folks there in ownership are
progressives but you should not be
listening in on your customers that's
called eavesdropping but that's what she
did and she chose to take that moment to
take a stand and I posted a tweet
immediately after which has had two over
two million views and now they're in
trouble because what she did to me was
plain and simple discrimination again
this is modern day Jim Crow If you don't
go with what the left wants you to go
with if you don't follow their narrative
completely then you're in trouble in
their eyes and that should not be the
case for any American it doesn't matter
what color you are you white black or
indifferent you should not be
discriminated against but that's what we
saw but I'm hoping that Governor Ron
DeSantis is going to take a very close
look at what's going on here because he
said no discrimination in Florida and
what I saw was discrimination well I'll
tell you I this has happened to me but
I'm angrier when it happens to my
friends like you as I wrote you this
weekend you handled it perfectly
um I admire all that you're doing for
your family you had a very tough upper
bringing yourself uh Gianna we think the
world thanks for being here his book by
the way amazon.com hannity.com taken for
granted how conservatism can win back
the Americans that liberalism failed hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else